hello i'm sasha larkin a captain with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
here to bring you the preliminary
details as we know them
on officer involved shooting number two
for 2021.
today tuesday february 9 just after 10
a.m
a call came in at the 800 block of east
silverado ranch of a domestic
disturbance
as officers arrived to that location
they encountered the female half
of the altercation on the second floor
landing of the apartment
they called her to come down the stairs
and as they did
the male half came out the door and
fired around
officers immediately returned fire and
the male half
went back into the apartment and the
female was safely taken out of the area
without injury a short time later
the male hit the window of the apartment
started to fire rounds again
at officers officers again returned fire
it is unknown at this point if the
suspect was hit by any rounds
at this point it's still a very dynamic
incident the apartment is surrounded and
the mail is still
inside the apartment with unknown
injuries
as you know in 72 hours the sheriff or
his designee will come forward
with the rest of the investigative
follow-up and all body worn camera
will be released thank you
for that there was no fire that we or fd
the fire department had to handle
what was their relationship a couple at
this point all we know is that they were
in the same space in some sort of dating
relationship who called police
uh that is unknown at this point have
you talked to the suspect at all
we have not any children in the
apartment not that we know of